- I get it.
- [Man] Even thought the
department keeps growing,
- Biggie said it right bro,
mo money, mo problems.
♫ We're unstoppable
what up vlog.
About to do a call, just
want to show you Babbin.
You know, just want to show
everybody the man behind
D Rock's success.
If the categories looked
at a different way,
they're gonna get
disproportionate opportunity.
There is some insane data
that is in their favor
because of (bleep) who
actually has (bleep)
and because I've been spending
the last year and a half
with the CEO, that's leading
to our big opportunity
over here, I disproportionately
know about the fact
that (bleep) a lot of ways
are really, really good
when you start figuring
out the impact of how much
(bleep) wasted and it's
impact on the environment.
Like it's, it's stunning
how good (bleep) is for the
world, but there's no
millennial mom that would
believe that.
I think Eric will probably
bring a little more detail
and nuance to this, but
that's the task at hand and
we have a big appetite
and a big opportunity and
I think they'll call my
bluff after we come with it
to let us execute the
influencer and Facebook video
work that I think can
actually achieve the success,
that's why I'm excited,
that's why we're on this call.
Got it?
- What's going on Gary?
Morning, morning.
- How's it going?
- [Lev] This came in yesterday.
- This came in yesterday, perfect.
D Lee.
Uh, I have really,
really, really bad news.
You bought the wrong jersey.
- [Lev] What do you mean?
- That's not his number anymore.
- Seriously?
- I'm being dead fucking serious.
- [Man] He's 58.
(inaudible Russian accent)
- You know what's funny?
Your Russian accent got heavier just now,
when the stress came
out, does that happen?
- I don't know.
- That was so fucking cool,
I just heard your Russian accent.
We need to get a new one,
fast, now, now you've got
real work to do, it's Friday,
start hustling, start hustling.
- We'll get this done.
- Yo, kids at home, when
you get me a jersey,
and your name is Lev,
you've got to really hustle
when the number's wrong, my man D Lee is
now number 58, this is last year's jersey.
You've got 48 hours my man, fix it.
(laughing)
- Okay, so I so fucked up.
Gary asked me to order him a Jet's jersey,
Darron Lee, so what I did, I went online,
saw the first jersey
that was Darron Lee's,
ordered it, it comes in,
but it's the wrong number.
What do I do now?
It's currently 2:16 PM
right now on Friday,
the game is on Sunday at
1 PM, I have 47 hours.
I need to find this jersey.
- Hello.
- Hi Gary.
- Hi, how are you?
- Good.
How you guys doing?
- [Group] Great.
- Good, awesome, how's it going so far?
Good?
- [Group] Yeah.
- You guys awake?
We good here, ha ha?
Google itself is a toll
booth for all of us,
and then the smart people
built companies on top of
Google to be another toll
booth on top of the Google
toll booth, so like the
reason I use that is,
I don't think people, a
lot of people if they don't
understand it, or even if
you're in it and been doing
it for years, I think
sometimes we don't think of
it enough as toll booths.
Like, these are, Google's a toll booth,
then all the leaders in your
businesses that are referral
sites and affiliate sites
are the next toll booth
and they were just better
at getting in front of
somebody before you and
the reason I believe in
brand so much, stuff that
most people in this room
hate because it's not quant,
it's not black and white,
it's not I spend four dollars
and I got three dollars
back, okay let me fuck with
it, okay I spend one dollar,
I get 13 dollars back, holy
fuck let me spend as much
on it as I can, the
reason everybody hates it,
is it's not measurable.
But it's the reason everybody's
here and I'm sitting here.
It's brand, and so the risks
you should all be taking,
we'll get to it one by one,
on brand, is extraordinary.
Because it fixes everything else out.
- Okay, so I'm in the car,
this is my last chance,
my only hope to find
this jersey I have 40,
about 46 hours remaining until game time,
if not today, hopefully tomorrow,
and then if not, then I
just have one last thing
to do and that's go to the
game, buy the jersey there,
and hopefully it'll be
good, if they have it.
- Bo, there's only one way
to win a family business,
radical candor.
And you know how easy that
is in a family business?
Almost impossible.
So I'm giving you advice
that's hard, radical candor,
and you're just gonna lose,
it's gonna eat you inside.
And I have good news for
you, this is the only chance
to have a good relationship with them,
not the other way around.
You think you're doing the
right thing to have a good
relationship with them,
you're leading to the things
that's gonna make you have
regrets and real issues
with them and you're gonna
snap and you guys are
gonna have a bad relationship.
- [Bo] Yeah, that's what I
feel like it's getting to
- Oh and you're fucking five
seconds in, second/third
generation family business
people pay the biggest tax
in the world, and when
they're fucking talented,
they really are fucked.
You know what family business
dynamics are good for?
Losers.
That's when you're lucky,
when you suck shit,
you're the one benefiting.
You know when family businesses suck?
When you're a winner.
And you're paying a tax
nobody's ever paid in life.
Guys I've built a business from
three to 60 million dollars
and left at 34 years
old with $100,000 in my
bank account, because I was
making myself $40-50,000
and zero equity on paper to
buy mortgage for me and my wife
because I owned zero
percent of my library.
How fucking lucky am I trolls on YouTube?
- The latest update,
it's almost four o'clock,
I'm in the car, driving
there's a little bit of traffic
- So you know what's happening
with all the ad agencies,
creative shops, why they're dead?
They started with art
and they hate numbers.
'cause art's a lot more fun,
because nobody can keep score.
So you just will yourself to
victory through headlines,
awards and being louder.
You're in a great spot,
when you bring Artie,
you know Rick or Sally,
you're gonna hold them
somewhat more accountable while,
let me give you good
piece of advice, do it,
bring in somebody who's above the line,
mean creative, whatever,
give them a budget
and don't scrutinize them.
What the three uncle's
fucked up with him is,
they should have just given him it,
and gotten the fuck out.
If you're gonna bring in
somebody to do creative
or be an editor in chief,
depending on how extreme you go,
this is for a lot of
you, just let, just say,
Sally $800,000, do you.
Make one KPI, the subjective
call of the two of you
that had actually brought
value at the end of one year.
Kim will tell you, the
way I manage, I'm like,
I'm not in it, but I'll
look at it at the macro,
because that's how I won, I've always won
'cause I do shit that makes no
mathematical sense up front.
Until it does, got it?
- yeah.
- So, and by the way, I can
give you another good piece
of advice, give that person
the amount of money that
you're most comfortable
with going to zero.
And then I've got the best part for you,
get 20 percent better at what you do,
so that it's a net equal.
If you're gonna give this person $100,000
make your $500,000 work
like $600,000 in 2018.
'cause you guys can get better
- for sure
- That's how you're gonna win, got it?
It's fun, you'll get better at your part,
which is just smart,
that frees up the 100,
'cause now 500,000 is being
is working as if it's 600,
'cause you're trying harder,
and you get to taste shit.
That's the way you build a business.
Guys, thank you so much.
Awesome, thank you,
- thanks.
- Thanks for coming, thanks for coming.
- Thank you so much.
- Uh, couple of meetings
now, can't film them,
then wrapping up and heading home,
for some family time.
Hope Babbin finds something funny,
let's see if Lev can get me
the jersey I'm looking for.
- So it's Saturday morning, just woke up,
about to go pick up this
jersey in a couple of hours.
It's time to get ready.
- And I'll see you next
week, a lot of hustle,
a lot of New York time, see ya.